you've probably heard the word parsec
before in science fiction movies or
maybe even in some things dealing with
astronomy and what i want to do in this
video is really just tell you where this
where the where the word and and the
definition of the word really come from
and just to kind of cut to the chase
it's just a unit of distance it's just
about 3.26
3.26 light years but what i want to do
is just think about where did this weird
distance come from this distance that is
roughly 3.26 light years it comes from
it comes from the distance
the distance
of something of something probably a
star but let me say something because
there are no stars exactly this far away
from us the distance of something whose
parallax or let me say that that has
that has
a
parallax
angle
of
one
arc
one arc second and the word comes from
the pair in parallax and the second in
arc second so it's literally
par
let me do this in a different color it's
literally
par
sec you could think of it as kind of the
parallax parallax arc second how far
would this thing be it turns out it's
3.26 light years and we can actually
calculate that and that's actually what
i'm going to do in this video so let's
say there is something
let's say so this is the sun
this is the earth at some point
in time this is the earth six months
later at the opposite end of the orbit
and we are looking at some distance
we're looking at some object some
distance away
we know that this distance right here is
one astronomical unit and
what we want to do is figure out the
distance of this object and all we know
is that it has a parallax angle of one
arc second so let's remind ourselves
what this means if we're looking right
at
right at remember we're looking from
above the solar system so the earth is
rotating in this direction in either
case
and so in in this point in the year we
don't know when this is depends on what
star that is at this point in the year
right at sunrise right when we first
catch the first glimpses of the sun's
light if we look straight up
if we look straight up the angle
the angle between that object in the
night sky and straight up is going to be
the parallax angle so this is going to
be 1
this is going to be 1 arc
arc second and just to make it
consistent with the last few videos we
did on parallax let's just visualize
that how that would look in the night
sky so let me draw the night sky over
here
let me do that in purple maybe
let me draw the night sky over here this
is looking straight up this is north
south
west and east and so you can imagine in
this situation the sun is just rising on
the east
the sun is just rising on the east let
me make it the color of the sun the sun
is just rising on the east and so this
will be towards the direction of the sun
you can imagine that to some degree well
this is north north is the top of the
earth right here kind of pointed towards
us out of the screen south is going into
the screen hopefully that helps the
visualization or another way to think
about it the sun is rising in the east
this is going to be towards the
direction of the sun of a certain angle
from the center in this case it's one
arc second so it's going to be right
over here so this this angle right over
here is going to be one
arc second and then if we were to see
where that object is six months later
it'll be the opposite we're going to be
looking we're going to be looking in the
same this the center of the universe or
i should say the center of the night sky
at that point the same direction of the
universe the universe actually has no
center we've talked about that many
times if we look at the same direction
the night sky we'll be looking six
months later
and instead of it being at dawn it will
now be at sunset we'll be just getting
the last glimpses of the sun and so the
sun will be setting
the sun will be setting in the west
the sun will be setting in the west and
so this
angle this angle right here which is
also the same thing as the parallax
angle it'll be this will also be one arc
second
so this will also be one arc second
one arc second so let's figure out how
far this object is what is what is an
actual parsec in terms of astronomical
units or light years so if this is one
arc second this is going to be and
remember one arc second is equal to 1 3
hundred
one thirty six hundredth of a degree
one thirty six hundredth of a degree so
this angle right over here
is going to be ninety
minus one over thirty six hundred and we
just use a little bit of trigonometry
the tangent of this angle the tangent of
90 minus 1 over 3 600
is going to be this distance in
astronomical units divided by one well
you divide anything by one it's just
going to be that distance so that's the
distance right over there
so we get our calculator out
and we want to find
the tangent
the tangent of
minus 1 divided by 3600
and we will get our distance in
astronomical units 200
6264. maybe 265 so this is going to be
equal to
this distance over here is going to be
265 i'm just rounding astronomical units
and if we want to convert that into
light years
we just divide
so there are 63
115 light years per astronomical unit
i'm sorry astronomical units per light
year so this is let me actually write it
down just so you make it i don't want to
confuse you with the unit cancellation
so we're dealing with
astronomical units and we want to
multiply that times one light year is
equal to 63
astronomical units and we want this in
the numerator and the denominator to
cancel out and so if you divide 200 6265
this number up here divided by
63115 the number of astronomical units
in a light year 63 115 let me delete
that right over there
we get 3.2 well the way the way the math
worked out here it rounded to 3.27 light
years
so this is equal to
this is equal to roughly
3.27 light years so i should just show
it's approximate right over there but
that's where the parsec come from so
hopefully now you just realize it is
just a distance but even more you
actually understand where it comes from
it's the it's the distance that an
object needs to be from earth in order
for it to have a parallax angle of one
arc second and that's where the word
came from parallax
arc second